- I heard there was a fight scene.
- Oh yeah yeah yeah.
- Y'all had a big fight team, right?
- Yeah, we had a huge fight scene.
- Like when you do that,
it's like choreography
like dancing, right?
- Yeah, we practiced-
Let me tell you about Idris' ass.
Check this out.
(audience laughs)
We practiced for two weeks
straight on this scene, right.
- [Kelly] Okay
- How to fight in the fight, right?
Two weeks.
We know it's so much, so
we like we ain't coming.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah
- First day on the set, we get there.
All of a sudden they go, action.
Bam, hits me in the head.
- [Kelly] Like, for real?
Knocks me on the ground.
I'm on the ground like this.
We just told his ass not to do this.
And then I get up and then
we've continued the fight.
And he was closer than what I thought.
And I ended up punching him.
- Whatever. You're like, okay,
if you will really hit me,
I'm gonna come hit you.
(Kelly laughs)
(Audience claps)
- I don't know what you're
talking about Kelly.
You're like all that rehearsal.
And you're like, oh my God.
Y'all really hit each other?
- The director was
like, no more accidents.
(audience laughs)
Nah. But yeah, he's a sweetheart man.
It was that intense.
And once you see the movie,
when you see my face,
the first hit and you see his
hit, those are actual hits,
and they used those.
Those is the actual hits.
There's one scene where
they hit the first scene
where he hit me.
I was like
(Audio bleeped)
(Audience laughs)
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to curse.
It's amazing. We'll bleep it.
Oh my god, that's amazing.
- I was falling back. Like,
did we just tell y'all.
(Kelly laughs)
- It's not supposed to be real
We're dancing!
(guest laughs)
What were these two weeks for?
- Two whole weeks!
- Oh my God.